developed in the 20th century
center-pivot sprinklers have become a
staple on large farms they custom design
each sprinkler for the field it will be
irrigating then they transform flat
high-strength steel into a water pipe
for the sprinkler system the steel
travels between forming tools and then a
series of rollers they curve the steel
upwards taking it from flat to
cylindrical more rollers squeeze the
pipe to close the gap then an automated
induction welder confuse the joint a
carbide blade trims excess metal from
the welded seam the metal is collected
on a spool to be recycled next they
douse the pipe with cooled a plasma
torch then moves along the pipe to cut
it into 40-foot sections
the pipes fall off the cutting line and
roll into a holding area
after the pipes have been inspected for
flaws a team clamps flanges to the ends
these flashes will be used to link the
water pipes in the field they weld the
flanges to the pipes next the welder
uses a plasma torch to cut outlets for
sprinkler heads he welds a threaded
fitting onto each outlet next an
employee assembles the sprinkler heads
she screws away to the plastic sprinkler
body to stabilize it then she snaps on a
spray nozzle the nozzles come in various
sizes for different applications finally
she adds a pressure regulator they ship
the parts of the sprinkler system to the
field they arrange the pipes on the
ground in the correct configuration
and set all the structural components
beside them then they start assembling
the immense sprinkler system beginning
with the triangular supports for the
water pipes they hoist the ends of two
pipes onto the supports and bolt them at
the flanges a crew member screws the
sprinklers two hoses
he connects the hoses to u-shaped
fittings screwed into the pipes
next they complete the electrical wiring
then they roll the wheels to the end
towers and bolt them to the gear motor
hubs by tapping into an underground
source the system can pump out water
through the sprinkler heads during a
drought this irrigation system can
provide a long pull drink for crops on a
hot summer day